well if you've watched this show for a
while you know that if there's anything
I'm passionate about it's Contemporary
Art Now by that I don't mean Modern Art
every true bona fide art Aficionado like
myself knows that the era of Modern Art
ended in the 1950s so when I say I like
Contemporary Art I mean the new stuff
post-modern art can't get enough of it
it's not just the use of technology and
text and angles and shapes that I'm into
that goes without saying speaking as a
connoisseur of the Fine Arts what I
really love about Contemporary Art is
how it's a conversation there's so much
interaction through their work
post-modern artists communicate with
other artists and that matters because
as Salvador Dali who I'm always quoting
said a true artist isn't one who is
inspired a true artist inspires others
so it was with great interest that
I observed the installation of a new
Statue earlier this year on Boston
Common talked about it on the show at
the time this was a statue that
supposedly was about honoring Martin
Luther King Jr but to all outward
appearances it was just a giant penis or
perhaps other body parts depending on
where you were standing when you looked
at it uh this wasn't my observation
everyone who looked at this thing of
course came to the same conclusion
including members of MLK's family and in
case you forget what it looked like uh
we'll we'll show this to you also just
because it's it's always funny to show
so here it is
the 22 foot tall bronze statue is called
the embrace the artist says it was
inspired by a photo of the couple
embracing moments after Dr King was
awarded the Nobel Peace Prize in 1964.
despite the good intentions though it
has left many confused trying to see the
Embrace
what else might you see I mean
everybody's wondering like can we see
this from a different angle I've been
I've been trying to see the Embrace
ladies and it's it's difficult right
all the conversation about this statue
at least among lay people in the
unwashed masses who are not art mavens
like myself was about how needlessly and
inexplicably pornographic the statue was
and what's the point of erecting a large
phallus-like object in a public area
that's what everyone was asking
and all the local news stations were
giggling about it as you just saw but
privately and with my many Associates in
the postmodern art community I was
asking another question and that
question was how are future artists
going to respond to this
what are the other Heroes of left-wing
post-modern art going to do in response
to the large black bronze uh penis
statue
how will they in the tradition of
Salvador Dali be inspired by it well it
took eight months but now I finally have
the answer to that question in Palm
Springs California the city's AIDS
Memorial task force has just produced
plans for a new monument one that
doesn't just respond to the 20-foot tall
bronze phallus in Boston but compliments
it really you'd be forgiven for thinking
that the same artist designed both
monuments indeed this is what
post-modern art is all about
and here's what the new monument looks
like watch
there are concerns tonight about Rays uh
being raised about an AIDS Memorial plan
for Downtown Palm Springs right now the
sculpture is planned to look like this
these pictures you're seeing here some
people don't like it NewsChannel 3's
Jake and Rossi live in studio with more
on the controversy and possible changes
in response to those concerns Jake and
John it is a nine foot sculpture plan
for a Palm Springs Park meant to
remember lives lost to HIV and AIDS but
the design doesn't resonate with
everyone in fact some call it
inappropriate and the committee in
charge says they are now listening
it's the proposed AIDS Memorial
Sculpture raising hundreds of thousands
of dollars in the community and stirring
up controversy over its shape the round
Limestone statue with concentric carved
circles meant to represent the diverse
Community impacted by AIDS its eye level
opening signifying connection reflection
and hope but it's not seen by everyone
that way some saying it's too abstract
it's really strained I mean it's this is
almost like a piece of art looking for a
purpose instead of the other way around
it could be about anything
and as consequence it's kind of about
nothing there's also the view that it
too closely resembles other things you
hear it called The Donut all the time
um you hear it called the word can't say
on camera all the time for some on
social media and Beyond the design
resembles an inappropriate body part on
the rear end the back side of the
proposed Memorial looks like
um a graphic depiction of the backside
of human being now
In that clip you heard from some haters
who don't know anything about art they
don't understand anything about how art
interacts with other art these are
bigots who don't care about the
connection that this Monument is
supposed to signify in more ways than
what instead they're offended by this
gigantic white Limestone anus they're
demanding revisions
think about that revisions May how
absurd can you be according to the Palm
Springs Post the designers of this white
butt statue spent eight years on this
eight years
coming up with this idea
and during the whole course of the eight
years nobody apparently looked at it and
said you know that that looks kind of
like an orifice uh it's a little bit of
a orifice like thing going on there
or maybe someone did say that and then
everyone was like that's fine though
it'll be fine and no one else is going
to notice that
which just as a general rule you would
think like if if you're making a statue
and it even a little bit looks like a
bodily orifice then just come up with a
different design
like if there's a if there's a two
percent chance that that people will see
it as an orifice then just come up with
it's just not worth it
but that's what you might think but
again this took eight years so let's
show some respect for context
that's longer than it took for the
Romans to build the Coliseum
and the Romans actually built it in in
eight years it's okay years just come up
with that design
so you know it has to be good there's no
way the government of Palm Springs could
possibly waste eight years on something
stupid and grotesque
plus the statue has already cost
something like half a million dollars
including tens of thousands of dollars
from the city's coffers and after all
that time they managed to produce a
statue that um
does what all great art should do
confuse and horrify people
that's money well spent if you ask me
yet according to the Palm Spring post
right wing bigots along with everyone
else with two sets two sets of uh uh
working eyes uh one or one set of
working eyes I guess anyway uh they want
to tear all that down
and I understand the skepticism here you
know we in the art community we haven't
done a lot to inspire trust lately it's
bad enough when some painting that looks
like vomit sells at auction for 90
million dollars or whatever people look
at Hunter Biden selling his finger
paintings for tens of thousands of
dollars to Anonymous buyers in China and
they conclude that the whole art scene
is just a giant money laundering
operation and I get it but what you
cavemen don't understand is that all
this post-modern art is doing is
reflecting the society we live in the
brilliant artists who constructed the
bronze phallus and the Limestone anus
are simply holding up a mirror
if you don't like what you see it's not
their fault
consider the fact that it's not just our
art that looks like this our buildings
are ugly too so is our music even our
people are ugly often intentionally so
so-called Beauty Brands are signify or
signing up morbidly obese women and
calling it Progressive
and all of this is intention is
intentional so I've been a little maybe
um
sarcastic and flip it about about this
which is a real change of pace for me
it's not like me to be sarcastic but but
all of this maybe makes the aid statue a
little less amusing once you think more
about it
because it's not just some one-off
perverted Monument it's not a gaff by an
artist who has no idea what he's doing
in fact it's part of a deliberate
campaign one I've talked about
extensively to throw ugliness in our
face everywhere we go that's why I took
eight years to make this thing they did
it on purpose this wasn't some rushed
draft it's perfectly in keeping with
what we're seeing all over the place as
you might know we are all fans of our
friends at genyourself don't just take
my word for it Ella from Rockford says I
have both age and acne spots and this
stuff is actually fading both of them
this Serum is worth every penny Ella's
raving about the famous Dark Spot
Corrector from geniuselli must have
after months of record heat and humidity
sunspots brown spots discoloration even
red inflamed patches are disappearing in
front of your very eyes when you use
genucel and here's a genuine cell
amazing guarantee you'll get results on
day one or your money back so take
advantage of geniusell's most popular
package which now includes the Dark Spot
Corrector plus the classic genucel bags
and puffiness treatment and immediate
effects all at about 70 off so you can
try the best skin care in the world for
your off completely risk-free and simple
go to genyourself.com Walsh and start
looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say goodbye to dark and liver
spots bags and puffiness under the eyes
and crow's feet at genucel.com Walsh
that's genusel.com Walsh
a century ago you know Cutting Edge
architecture in this country was Art
Deco and it was instantly recognizable
from Rockefeller Center in the Empire
State Building to the Carlisle hotel in
Miami Beach before that we had
neoclassical architecture which
describes many of the buildings on
Capitol Hill and most Americans prefer
that kind of architecture by the way a
survey from the national Civic Arts
Society from 2020 showed that this
traditional architecture is preferred
among all demographic groups you know it
doesn't matter education age ethnicity
or whatever what we have now what no one
wants is homogeneous architecture being
made by the same people and copy pasted
all over the country
as New York Times recently reported in
2021 quote five of the 25 largest
developers were responsible for starting
construction on nearly 47 000 units in
the United States about 40 percent of
the output of the whole group the CEO of
Greystar real estate Partners which is
responsible for more of those units than
anyone else told the times that many of
their buildings look the same because of
government regulations quote I don't
want to say that's colored by the
numbers but in some cities it's color by
numbers
now if you assume the Greystar CEO is
telling the truth that we have no reason
to think he's lying then you still have
to answer a fundamental underlying
question if you grant that governments
are mandating homogeneous ugly
architecture which seems to be a safe
assumption then you still have to figure
out why that's happening like why is the
government telling developers that they
can't produce creative interesting
structures like the ones we built a
century ago
given everything else we know about the
government the answer seems obvious
you know like it comes down to the point
uh that uh that that beauty points
inevitably to God and when western
civilization was Christian it created
the greatest works of art mankind has
ever seen in the most beautiful
buildings and everything else
now Western governments are secular and
it's no surprise that it produces
therefore the dreariest art mankind has
ever seen
our Elites want us demoralized and
depressed they want us high on legalized
pot as we listen to lectures on how
racist we are as we're staring at the
same uninteresting buildings that
everyone else in the country is looking
at and gawking at sculptures that look
like body parts below the waist
beautiful art has the opposite effect it
reminds us that there's a greater power
than any of us greater than any
government
it tells us the the importance of
creativity and soul and risk taking
and our government can't have that
so instead of beauty we get butt
sculptures and hideous buildings and rap
songs where semi-literate drug addicts
shout about their genitalia
now perhaps on second thought I'm No Art
Expert I don't even know what
post-modern art is honestly if I'm being
honest what I do know is that the
phallus statue and the butt Monument are
individually hilarious but taken
together they're profoundly depressing
especially when you compare what ancient
civilizations were able to create in the
amount of time it takes us to sculpt a
giant rectum
this is a sign of cultural rot of the
decline of morality and passion and
original thinking in the United States
maybe the artist of question didn't
intend to send that message
maybe they didn't intend the butt and
the phallus to be any kind of metaphor
but uh it is one
and anyone has ever driven through
downtown Seattle or Nashville or Denver
any number of major American cities
knows that
and that is why ultimately post-modern
artists and soulless government
bureaucrats and everyone else who wants
to suppress what's left of creativity
and humanity and Beauty in this country
are today all canceled hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plans see you
there